- In the last year, I've been approached
by people asking about their AI costs
that I wasn't prepared to answer.
For some of you in the
audience, this might be a CFO,
asking about the ROI on model training,
maybe an engineer asking for
budget approval for GPUs,
or a board member asking about
the cost of your AI strategy.
Whoever, whatever the question is,
hopefully you'll be happy
to hear you're not alone
if you're feeling unprepared.
My name is Catherine Graham.
I lead the Optics team.
It's a finops team within AWS.
- Hey everybody, my name's Chris Hennessy
and I'm on the executive
in residence team.
I'm really excited to be here today,
and prior to being on that
team for the last five years,
I was a technology CFO at
Capital One for 20 years.
So excited to share insight
from that experience
and from the content
we created here today.
- And today we're gonna talk
to you about AI for finops
and finops for AI in the hopes
to educate and enable you.
And in preparation for
today's presentation,
Chris and I spoke with
over a dozen leaders
from different companies about
their AI and finops journeys.
And in doing so, I
shockingly found parallels
to my personal life.
So I wanna start with
a quick personal story
and then we'll get started.
So four years ago, my husband and I
were planning for our second kid.
And some of you in the audience
may recognize this misplaced confidence,
but we were going in thinking,
okay, hey, we've done this before.
How hard can it be?
It can't be that different.
Fast forward about two
weeks after my son was born,
we found out he was deaf.
All of a sudden
information is flying at us
at a rapid speed.
Lots of unknowns, lots of uncertainty.
To say we were overwhelmed
is an understatement.
But we had people in our
corner, subject matter experts,
a community helping us with the transition
and helping us make decisions.
Why am I sharing this with you?
And what on earth does
my son being born deaf
have to do with AI or finops?
It was in the conversations
that we had with these leaders
that we saw not just a parallel
into expecting the
unexpected or those unknowns
that I mentioned, but in the
advice the leaders we're giving
to people just starting this journey.
So I wanna share four of those with you
and then we'll dive in.
So first, you're not alone.
May feel like you are, you're not.
Second, focus on the real problem.
I was focusing on the
fact that my son was deaf.
That wasn't the problem.
The problem was communication.
If you can focus on real problems
that your customers are having
or real pain points your
teams are experiencing,
you will deliver value.
Don't overcomplicate it.
Finops 101, cloud financial
management basics,
those principles still apply.
The variables are different.
And then last, never stop learning.
I thought we had the proper tools in place
for kid number two and we
had a decent foundation,
but we still had to learn
new and different things.
We had to learn a completely
different language.
And the same thing is true here,
and this isn't just parenting advice,
but our hope today after you leave,
if that CFO, board
member, engineer, comes up
and asks you about AI costs,
you'll have a better answer.
So let's get started.
- Great, and as we look at the elements
of what we're gonna cover in
terms of the perfect storm,
there's a convergence
of activity happening.
I think all of us see how much
cloud growth is occurring.
If you look at any cloud provider,
it's in that 20 to 40% per year.
But AI growth is at a much
larger clip that we're seeing
and that's across all of the ecosystems
and all of the players.
The other thing as we see as
we go through this specifics
are there's a lot that's
changing and new nomenclature
and dynamics you need to
learn as you go through this,
specifically on the AI side.
So understanding some of
the terms, the dynamics
and how that fits into the finops practice
is something we're gonna cover here today.
And then lastly,
you need to focus on both
sides of the equation.
This isn't all about cost for cost sake,
it's about the value articulation.
And that's an area that
we see as a blind spot
and came up with a lot of
our customer conversations
that we had.
So today we're gonna look at both sides.
It's almost two sides of the coin.
One is how can you leverage
AI to enable finops?
And then specifically how
do you bring finops into AI
and the capability that exists there.
So as we start out, there's
this convergence that happens
in terms of this and there's
a good overlap that exists.
And there's three key areas we saw
as we had conversations with customers.
The first is on intelligence.
I think a lot of us have
leveraged AI in both your personal
and professional life as a
way to help with interaction
and prompting and engaging.
It's a way to provide answers
and insights to the
information that exists.
Automation is a big deal within finops.
I know most of the
companies that I meet with,
the finops team is usually
one to three people,
even in large enterprises.
It's really trying to scale
through the engineering community
and help them self sustain.
So automation is a key element of that.
And then lastly, it's
all about getting scale
and democratizing this
to the organization.
A lot of the use cases we're gonna share
that we learned from customers,
it's finding ways to scale
and get more reach and benefit
and insight to those who need
it inside of the organization.
- And one thing that's
important to remember
is you don't need all three on day one,
or even in year one to add value.
The importance is remembering
that the value lives in the intersection,
and that's when AI stops
being just an experiment
and starts being a business enabler.
For finops, it stops being
about just cost control
and starts being about
proactive optimization.
So just to set up the next 45 ish minutes,
we're gonna start with AI for finops.
How are we using AI to transform
cloud financial management?
What are the challenges?
How are leaders approaching it?
What's actually working?
Then we're gonna jump to finops for AI.
How do you budget for something
that's constantly changing?
How do you determine
a return on investment
or build a strategy?
Then we'll wrap with
tips, advice from leaders
and some educational recommendations.
But before we do that, can
everybody get out their phone?
I can't believe I'm
actually saying that during-
- We're gonna do a roll
the dice analogy on this.
So you know when you bring a survey out,
it could either go well or not.
So we're hoping it goes well.
So we'd love to get insight for you all
to get perspective from those in the room.
So the first question you'll
hear and you'll see up there
is where is your organization
in the AI journey?
There's four options,
you can only vote once,
but would love to get your insight.
And we're gonna share the
results here in a minute
so everyone can see.
- I'm gonna keep it up
there just for a sec.
And then there's another one.
Where do you think most organizations
are in their AI journey?
And as you're doing this,
I just wanna mention,
several months ago when Chris
and I started planning
for this presentation,
we decided from the
beginning that we wanted this
to not just be cloud agnostic,
but to reflect the reality
of what our customers
are going through and
to include action items
that y'all can take as soon as possible.
And so that's why we
had these conversations,
to check our bias and
hopefully what we learned
and share with you today is helpful.
So let's see if this worked.
- All right, we're gonna see if it works.
Before I do, I'd love maybe your estimate
on the first question.
If you could go back, I know
people are taking pictures.
What do you think the
predominant answer is?
- I mean, originally before,
not to give the answer away,
not that there's a right answer,
I thought it would be
piloting specific use cases.
Did you think something different?
- I thought it was the same as well.
But we're gonna try the
toggle here the answers,
let's see if it works.
All right, almost 300 of you responded
and it is a little bit
leaning more on the lower end
of the piloting specific use
cases takes the majority there.
- I'm like smart group,
that's what I thought too.
- All right, you wanna go
back to the second question?
If anybody has an answer, feel free to-
- We're in there.
- Answer that.
- The fact that it's been smooth
is nice, the polls so far,
knock on wood.
- Did the second survey work for everyone?
Yes, it did, I see it now.
All right, it wasn't on there.
Little less participation,
maybe the two QR codes.
We only have one back to back.
So on this one, let's
look at the results here.
Where do you think most are?
And it's in the same wheelhouse,
similar vein in that same-
- Little bit more.
- Phase.
A little bit skew to the left.
- All right.
- Perfect.
And is any good CFO,
you'll see throughout the
presentation, I love data,
data to help inform information.
So as you look at this chart,
and again we're
specifically focusing on AI
for finops here on the front
end, what do you all think?
Any guesses on what this
chart may represent?
- Or like anyone?
- How many orgs are doing AI finops.
That's a very good estimate,
good forecast there.
So as you look at it, of all
the companies we talked to,
only about 10% were at scale
of using AI for finops.
All the examples
that we're gonna talk
through in the use cases,
it's very early in the journey.
So the you're not alone
analogy you gave earlier,
I think that's where a
lot of customers are.
I know I meet with hundreds
of customers in a year
and a lot of them are looking
for use cases, proof points.
They want to see and understand
where do they actually
see value for AI's sake
versus maybe just having to
feel like you have to do AI
and everything, which is,
I know what a lot of customers feel.
So the first topic I'm gonna talk about
is when not to use AI
and specifically gen AI.
I think, I know there's a lot
of pressure in the ecosystem
of AI, AI everywhere,
but I think when we met with
customers it was very clear
as you think about finops,
there's a lot better solutions
and especially more cost effective
solutions on certain ways
of leveraging capability,
especially in forecasting.
I know many of you have
probably done forecasting
in your experience.
And there's better machine
learning capabilities,
other analytical capabilities
that you can balance.
So we thought it was
important to frame out.
One thing that popped in the conversations
is what are some of the use
cases of when not to use AI?
And as you look at this,
especially as you think
about the financial side,
the difference between
probabilistic with generative AI
and deterministic drives a big difference
in terms of what you can
use and when you can use it.
And this decision tree just
gives a little bit of an insight
of what you should use when you need it.
And we're gonna dive a
little bit more specifics
into what some of the customers shared
on this slide as well, the next one.
As you look at some of the capabilities
that are here that exist
in some of the use cases,
forecasting's obviously a great one.
I know I've spent some time
recently trying to leverage AI
on the generative AI side
to help predict patterns.
I think Agentech will
do a better job of this
than generative,
but I know a lot of great
services exist both within Amazon
and within partners that leverage
more traditional analytics
and do a really good job in that.
You also need to balance
as we'll go through,
there's a big balance we
have in putting this together
around what's the value expected
versus the cost that's informed.
So that framing is a
really important framing
as you go through this.
So we just wanted to make sure
and start out the conversation,
the answer for everything isn't AI,
there's different solutions
that can be applied to this
and it's something you
need to keep in mind
as you go through it.
- So the reality is, is
that there are challenges,
and these aren't all encompassing,
but what I wanna do is touch on a few
that made a repeat appearance.
So we've got the data
quality and preparation.
This came up in every single
one of our conversations.
This is the hard part,
not AI, not the tools.
And most customers are doing this,
but they're doing it retroactively,
which can be painful and expensive.
Then we've got multi-cloud.
Most of the organizations
are running multi-cloud.
And if you're doing that,
you've got different billing construct,
different terminology.
And in order for AI to be useful,
you have to normalize that
data into a common framework.
Then we have what I call the
trust gap, hallucinations,
AI reliability.
We had one leader mention to us
that their system recommended
a $12 million savings
by buying document DBRIs.
It sounds good, but those
don't exist currently.
AI has the ability to increase
productivity 10 plus X,
but if we're not careful,
it can make more work
or worse cause distrust for
our customers or our teams.
Skill shortage.
Most people aren't great
at writing prompts,
and this doesn't even begin
to touch on the technical gap
that compounds this challenge.
And then integration,
the people, the processes, the systems,
the operational friction
points that can add up
and demotivate people
from using the systems
that may actually help them.
So I'm sharing these to let you
know that they're universal,
not to discourage,
but let's see how leaders
are approaching it.
We had a lot of conversations,
but these are the four
main themes that came out.
Build the foundation, all about the data.
Buy proven solutions
focused on the tooling.
Enable with guardrails, the culture.
And then the process,
experimentation and iterating.
Let's dive in a little bit
deeper on what these look like.
So build the foundation, data first.
This is fundamental.
This is what I call table stakes.
No amount of AI can compensate
for a poor data foundation.
And you'll hear me say
that multiple times today.
Buy proven solutions.
There was a time when buy
versus build was a real debate,
but it seems that in AI for finops,
it's mostly resolved and it's buy.
The landscape is moving so fast.
One interesting thing
though we did find out
is that customers commitment timelines,
those are changing from annual
to quarterly or even monthly.
So the customers can keep up
with that fast paced change.
- The next one we saw as a trend
was around the culture, around enablement.
This notion of experimentation
and freedom to test
and have fun and and see how
you can guide within this.
So ensure there's guardrails that exist.
I know recently I was in Mexico City,
and I meet with a lot of banks
just given my banking background,
and they're obviously very worried
as most are around security and data,
especially their customer information.
They don't want that
being trained on LLMs.
They wanted to make sure
they retain that in-house.
And while they were building
the foundation of the elements
of building out LLMs to be
available for their workforce,
they had a lot of pride
of not having access
for their internal associates to LLMs.
And as they went through that, I was like,
oh, okay, have you set that
expectation for your workforce?
And they're like, oh
yeah, it's very clear.
And I literally walk out
of the conference room
and someone's on ChatGPT,
putting company information
into a public ChatGPT,
and I'm like cringing.
So you have to have
the guardrails in place
and the expectations.
That doesn't mean every associate
can do whatever they want.
You have to be clear
around those guardrails
and the culture that you
want to create within that.
And the last one is around learning first,
this notion of experimentation
and starting small.
We get a lot of questions I
know in in the job that we're in
around how do you get started?
How can you even begin to
experiment at using AI for finops?
And I think the whole
mantra we all have heard,
which is start small, think
big is a good mantra here.
I think I always try to focus
on a pain point in an area
where there's an
opportunity, varying ways,
and I'm sure you all
have heard many of these,
of how do you have promptathons
specifically locally
for people to learn about that.
How do you encourage peer-to-peer connects
with maybe someone who's more
advanced and less advanced?
How do you create the
environment and the time?
It's usually about time trade-offs
that come up with customers
of being able to learn
and experiment as a part of using this.
So the first case study,
we're gonna do three or four of these,
was actually in a large bank
and how they were driving
through their AI evolution.
And the challenge they were
having just like many of us
is you needed to have a
little bit of deeper knowledge
to be able to answer the
questions from the product owners
and the engineering community.
And some of the harder questions
took a little bit more time
and there was a very small
level of capacity of analysts
who can actually support this.
So they were looking at a way,
can AI really help build this
and solve this?
And they really focused first on one,
could they have a gen AI
kind of chat bot solution
on top of the data to
enable people to self-serve?
They knew they wouldn't
answer every question,
but they were hoping if
they could pair that data
along with historical analysis
they've done using RAG
as a way to bring that insight to bear.
And what they saw when
they started creating it,
it caught on like wildfire.
They had a 20 times increase in reach,
specifically around the
adoption of the tool.
They were able to enable
people to self-serve
as a part of it.
And it was a very small
level of investment
to build this out and be able to see this.
And the customer quote was,
this isn't about just
giving people more data,
it's trying to provide
answers and insights to them
to enable this.
So this is one of the use cases
that we saw from a customer interview
that we were really excited to
see it was being put to use,
especially for the
group that was in scale.
- So let's look at the value chain
and what it looks like in real life.
So it starts with the
raw data and metadata.
This is not just your
cost and usage reports.
This is context, business events,
seasonal patterns, org structure.
Then you've got your data
normalization and quality.
This is when you're
translating across clouds.
This is invisible to the
end user but critical.
Then you have AI processing and analysis.
This is when the machine learning
is actually doing the work.
Insights and human review.
Do you wanna be confident in
the decision or the action?
Because if you do, you wanna
get explainability in there
or human review.
If you've got a system
that says, Hey Catherine,
let's right size 500 instances.
Okay, why?
What's the risk if I do,
what's the risk if I don't?
Is confidence high, is it low?
If it's low, let's get a human in there.
If it's high, let's kick it over
to the developer's queue for approval.
Then you have automated
and semi-automated actions.
I say semi-automated
because even the most mature organizations
are keeping humans in the loop.
And then last, outcome,
measurement and learning.
Did the optimization work?
Did it save costs?
Was performance stable?
You wanna feed what you
learned back into the system
so AI gets smarter with time.
And you'll notice it's a
loop and not a straight line
because the actions
should train the system
and the outcomes should
continuously refine the model.
- So there were three
themes that popped out,
I'll go ahead and put 'em
all up, in the conversations,
and it's from most popular to
early stages of development
on the other side.
The no-brainers are the
conversational interfaces.
These are the use cases
probably you've seen grow
in the last year as gen
AI has been fully adopted.
How do I use our internal information
along with leveraging
a large language model
to enable capabilities
and reach that exists.
And there's a lot of good examples
of customer questions that exist there.
The middle is where things are evolving
and it's growing much faster,
which is how can I have,
either potentially an
agent work on my behalf
or escalate and elevate thing exceptions.
There's a lot of great
anomaly detection solutions.
AWS has them.
But this is a way
in which you can start
internally leveraging this
on other data sets just beyond
your cloud and usage data.
And then last is everyone's nirvana,
which is how can I automate some of this?
How can I enable
potentially Agentic agents
to do this on my behalf?
I know I've been a little close
to how this is evolving
both in the startup
and the large company ecosystem.
And it's coming quickly.
I think the pace of change is happening.
So this was an area we didn't see a lot of
in the customers we met with,
but there's a lot of
talks of the development
that they're doing as a part of this
and where they're beginning to focus.
So one SaaS company we met
with to do the next case study,
specifically was beginning
to narrow in on this.
And again, slightly
similar to the first one,
not a lot of people, but a
lot of demands on their team.
And I know many of you feel that same way.
And you'll see the last one,
engineers avoided finops.
I led a finops team and sort
of finops team for a long time
and it's a hard team to be on
because not that engineers
don't wanna do the right thing,
but there's a lot on engineers plates.
And when you're trying to
take their capacity away
from developing features
and asking them to optimize,
there has to be really good
incentive for them to do that
to focus on that.
So in this case that was
true for this SaaS company.
The engineers were trying
to avoid the finops team.
So as you think about the
solution that they built...
- Is it not coming through?
- It's not going for me,
but maybe for you.
- No, it was going too smoothly.
- Yeah, yeah, the survey I
thought would take us down,
so I didn't think the...
Lemme see there.
I'll just did page down that worked.
All right, the other big thing,
I know I talk to customers a lot,
is you don't want to create
a bunch of dashboards
and expect people to look at them.
You need to bring information
to where engineers work.
And I know for me in the past,
big areas where both GitHub and Slack,
those were areas where a lot of engineers
were spending time.
So how do I bring financial data there?
And this SaaS company did the same.
They integrated with Slack
in terms of notification capabilities
and natural language queries
directly within Slack
that enabled them to
deliver this information.
And the results were incredible.
They had a hundred times
increase in the user community
of relative to what was
being reviewed before
to what was then being
accessed and leveraged then.
They could monitor the conversations
and the questions look for key themes
and patterns of those questions,
and they'd elevate FAQs
and other things as a part of it.
And it was really
driving a cultural change
inside of the organization.
And the quote from the customer
as you read through it,
it's take data where engineers are.
That was the big takeaway for them,
which is that was the breakthrough
when they started to see the
change specifically there.
One question we get a lot,
and this is just to give a
timeline for the same company,
they started out in almost like a pilot
kind of agile sprint kind
of construct within this,
this is the timeline they leveraged
in terms of building out the capability.
They focused on 10
development teams as a start
to really work out the kinks
and then scaled it to over 500 users
inside of the organization.
So as you all I know are
experiencing the pace of change
with AI and LLMs is moving quickly,
it's also the true with how
people are leveraging it
inside the company and trying
to bring those mindsets
to kind of fail fast and
move quickly as a part of it.
So next up is another survey question.
So if you pull out your phone again,
would love to hear from you on this one,
which is what's preventing
faster AI adoption
in your finops practice?
There's four options, choose one.
But if you don't mind
sharing your insight,
we don't want to taint the audience-
- I know.
- But I know we talked
a little bit before about what-
- We did.
And I don't wanna give...
I thought it was gonna be one thing.
I was pretty confident.
And through these conversations
I learned I was wrong,
very wrong, but it was humbling to learn.
- Great, got some great results here.
Pull it up.
- There's only one more.
- One more survey.
All right.
And the results are, it's
pretty evenly distributed.
Expertise is probably the one-
- That's what I thought it was.
So I'm glad I'm a aligned
to the audience, you know.
Okay, let's see if this works.
Hold on, is mine working again?
It is.
So while we wrap the first section,
if you're gonna remember anything,
let it be these three things.
So data quality over everything.
No amount of AI can compensate
for that poor data foundation.
Trust, but verify, use AI to
do 80% of the heavy lifting
but keep humans in the loop.
And then problems not wishlists.
Focus on something that changes behavior
or saves time, money,
if it doesn't delay it.
All right, so now that we've
talked about how we use AI
to manage costs, let's talk
about managing the cost
of AI itself.
So I wanna start with a quote
from one of the leaders we spoke to
'cause I feel like it
frames up this topic nicely.
So I'm just gonna give a
minute for everyone to read.
So I like this for multiple reasons,
but I wanna call out two specific ones.
First it's something that I
mentioned at the beginning,
reminding us to not overcomplicate things.
And then the second thing,
which was our biggest
takeaway in our conversations
is that AI is not that different.
- And as you balance kind of
the notion of traditional cloud
and the AI workloads,
there's some differences.
And I know this comes up pretty actively
as we talk to customers,
some may laugh about
predictable patterns with cloud.
I know I get a lot of questions
of how do I forecast cloud,
how do I expect it?
But relative to AI, it's much spikyier
in terms of consumption within AI
than it is within the cloud.
As you read through the rest,
there's a little bit more of,
I think it's just a
little bit more maturity
and knowledge on the
traditional cloud side.
And it's new on the AI side.
I do think you've called
out the one which was,
how do I make common
nomenclature across providers
that I'm leveraging?
That definitely has come up
in our customer conversations.
But I think the key is the
principles are the same.
And that was true in every
conversation we had, which is,
although there's different terms,
although there's a different
dynamic, it was clear
that we had the mechanisms in place
between how do we hold
leaders accountable,
how do we plan for these elements?
While it's a little bit different,
it was very similar in terms
of the optimization structure itself.
And what better way than
the iceberg analogy.
- Yeah.
And you you don't wanna
miss make the mistake
and only budget for what you can see.
You also wanna plan
and consider everything
below the waterline.
And it's the data preparation
that I've been mentioning,
integration, fine tuning, training.
- Yeah, and the hard thing
about the things on the bottom
is it's taking existing
capacity to do that.
So a lot of times customers are saying,
oh I can plan for the top
because I can point to it,
but if you look at the bottom,
it's around redirecting
your capacity of your teams
to do this work.
So that takes prioritization
and trade off,
which is not an easy thing to do.
And I know a lot of customers
are focusing on that.
So just make sure as you go through this,
you don't ignore that.
Just because it may be
viewed as a sunk cost
of capacity internally, it is capacity
that could be directed elsewhere.
So make sure you're considering that
as you go through the focus.
- And this is a high level
simplified checklist,
but we wanna run through it.
So budget for about 30 to
40% for data preparation.
Your finops team capacity,
if you're scaling AI,
you're probably gonna wanna
scale your finops team as well.
Budget and plan for governance,
integration, training,
about 20 to 30% for
experimentation and failure.
And then org change management.
But once you plan for all that, what next?
GPU capacity.
This is something we've all seen
or heard and/or experienced it.
And it is a big ticket
item, big light item,
and it's a big challenge to manage.
- So another case study we
did was with a global bank.
They had a pretty good
analysis and a framework
to leverage on making trade-offs
that were necessary around that GPU
we thought we'd share with you.
So the challenge is, as you
know, it's scarce capacity,
at least for in some instances.
And a lot of times, even when
you allocate that capacity,
it's unclear of how it's
actually being leveraged,
especially inside of the organization.
In this one, it was a highly
federated organization.
So every business had kind of freedom
and rights to do what they want.
They just allocated
capacity in the aggregate.
And once you do that,
you kind of lose insight
and visibility into how
it's being leveraged.
So they decided to build a framework
and an approach to help solve that.
So this got very detailed,
I know when we were reviewing with them,
they had 19 unique GPU metrics
that they were looking at
around utilization and
the specifics of that.
They were trying to aggregate those
to understand where the
patterns and utilization was.
But the big element was
how do we give visibility
around the usage patterns
and elevate where that was being done
to make sure it was delivering
the most value to the organization.
And they had a really good
two by two, which I loved,
so I wanted to share with you as well.
And there's nothing better
than a good two by two
to frame a conversation.
But if you look at the bottom,
it's usage on the Y axis,
it's criticality, and
there's some no-brainers,
especially on the bottom left,
if it's low utilization of a GPU
and it's providing low
criticality to the business,
get rid of it, redirect
that capacity elsewhere.
The top right, it's all about
high value, high criticality.
There could be ways to optimize that.
But I think thinking of
what are the use cases
in your company?
How are you leveraging
this kind of scarce capacity that exists?
And is there some framing
or approach you can put in
place to ensure that you
and your leaders are making
the best decision possible
for your customers.
- So now that we plan for the budget,
let's talk about recognizing ROI.
Get out your phones one last time.
What's preventing you from
measuring your AI ROI today?
This is another one
that I felt like we had differing
point points of view on.
But I'll be curious what the results are.
- The response rate has
dwindled every single question.
- Ouch.
- That's one observation.
- We won't read too much into it.
- Yeah, yeah, we won't read much into it.
Done with the surveys.
All right, now we're back
even over the last question.
Great, and the results are,
scattered costs and no metrics is one,
no metrics number one and two.
But again, fairly evenly
distributed as well there.
Perfect, so I'm gonna dive deep into this
because I know for me,
I feel like I've spent my
career creating business cases,
and I know if any of you have done that,
it's pretty easy to
create a business case.
It is very hard to track it
after you are going live.
It's a mix master of information.
But I think from a framework standpoint,
the nice thing about a kind
of a traditional ROI analysis
on the front end is
there's cost investments
that are necessary,
there's expected benefits
as you go through 'em,
you can tie things back
pretty easily to a cause
and effect for most things,
not everything but most things.
And I think once you
introduce AI into the mix,
things change a little bit
'cause there's a lot of
second and third order impacts
as you go through this.
And I think there was a good example here,
which is an externally facing chat bot.
And I'm not sure many of you probably have
your own experiences
with certain providers
and consumer experiences,
when they may be added capability
and you can start getting answers quickly,
you feel like it's better service,
things are improving, that's
awesome, that's really good.
Brand perception's improving,
customer satisfaction's improving.
But as you think back internally,
I meet with a lot of CFOs,
one CFO said to me, I
need numbers, not stories.
This isn't about feel good around this.
I want to know how that
translates to either the P and L
or to performance and
metrics that are there.
So I get a lot of questions specifically
around how to measure this.
And I think there's a couple of things
that come as challenges.
One, we mentioned the iceberg,
which is the denominator effect.
There tends to be a lot more cost
that's involved than
you're actually quantifying
as you go through some of this.
On the numerator side, I know
most organizations struggle
with value articulation,
and that can range from
being a private enterprise
where you're for profit,
to a government entity
where it's mission driven.
It's a totally different
conversation of value creation.
And then the last one is,
it's kind of a moving target
in terms of timeline and expectation.
So these are the three
patterns that came up
and have come up in customer conversation.
The first one is the productivity paradox.
All of us have experienced this.
When you've leveraged AI
to do something in an everyday task,
it can provide a great experience
and it can do things better
and faster, which is awesome,
that's great.
But, and the example here
is on the queue developer,
just 'cause you can code
faster, what does that mean?
Does that mean better quality?
Does that mean more features?
What does that actually translate to
in terms of customer value?
That's one of the challenges
that customers have.
The second is a baseline absence.
I know I always love to ask
the question to IT leaders,
do you track time?
And I know that's a
thorn in everyone's side
in terms of time tracking,
like I don't need
somebody looking after me
and what's going on.
But baseline creation is really important
as you go into this.
I spend also a lot of time
on total cost of ownership
of cloud or of IT cost.
If you don't know where you're starting,
it's very hard to know what's
changed and how it's evolved.
And as you think about this,
there's a lot of activities we do
that you just don't measure
and it almost doesn't make
sense to measure in this regard.
But that's where some of
the challenges are coming.
What was it before, what is it after
and what do I do with it?
And then lastly is the diffusion of value
that was one of the items
that was called out there,
which is there's almost this
downstream impact of things
that can be unearthed
as you go through this.
But how do you quantify
some of these items?
We've always had struggle, I
know on the qualitative side
of if you're more secure,
how do you translate that
to an articulation of value?
You could say we're more secure,
but what does that actually translate to
in terms of performance?
Obviously a lot of this is reputation risk
and a little things that are softer
'cause they are mitigating events,
but those are the things that come up
as a challenge that's there.
So there's a couple of things
I've seen some patterns of what's working
and what's not working.
A lot of times people say if
you save time, you save money.
And I know for many one of us,
we've probably gotten more
productive in the last year
and a half in certain ways.
Some ways maybe not as
much, but some ways we have.
That doesn't mean you don't need us,
it's still resources that are necessary.
So just because you
save time in the stories
of I saved 1000 hours,
most I know financially minded
people are gonna be like,
that's 1000 hours, that's a lot of money.
Where's that going?
Where's that being redirected to?
So a lot of this is resource reallocation
that exists in companies.
The second is around revenue attribution.
When you roll out a
capability or a service,
I know I work with a lot
of ISV and SaaS companies
that are looking to build AI
into a lot of their solutions now.
So they're thinking
about how do I price it?
How do I assess this?
What's the value that's
expected through this?
So just because you add that,
it's very hard attribute revenue
only to that in isolation.
The third is around cost
avoidance, the age old, which is,
if I didn't have this, I
would've had to hire these people
or I would've had to do this.
While that's a good
storyline in aggregate,
sometimes it can feel like phantom money
when you talk about it,
but it's a real thing.
So I think it's important
as you go through this,
I've used this wisely as you
specifically go through it.
And lastly is around efficiency metrics.
I'm a big believer in metrics and ratios,
but as you go through this,
be careful of the cumulative
effect of all the ratios
'cause if you add up all
these ratios together,
it seems like you don't
need a team or a resource
or something else that's there.
So if that's true, that's great,
but if it's not, be really
mindful of the words you use
and the metrics you use
as you go through it.
So there's three patterns I've seen
to be successful for companies
as they think about value articulation.
One is something called
kind of a value driver,
think of like a value tree,
which is there's primary
measurable items, lower cost,
less losses, more revenue.
That's very clear, that's
a traditional measure.
But the secondary areas
you need to make sure
you're articulating as well.
You may not have numbers
behind all of them,
but you need to have the the
qualitative assessment of that
and not ignore that as
you're talking about returns.
The second around outcome based
metrics, this is something
that came up at a lot of
the conversations we had,
which is how do I think
about what the outcomes
of these activities are so
that we are measuring that.
Sometimes that in
isolation won't tell you,
but this in concert with
the one on the value tree
will definitely help.
But the one that's
probably resonated the most
is this portfolio approach,
which is thinking like a VC firm.
And as you know with a VC firm,
they make a lot of investments.
I know there's always
the soundbite out there,
nine outta 10 businesses fail.
So that means you need
to start 10 businesses
'cause one will be successful.
It's the same construct here,
not that nine will fail with AI,
but it is an element of you
do need multiple avenues
and things stokes in the fire,
'cause some will work out
and some won't work out.
I was at an event two
weeks ago in New York
around AI and finance,
and someone speaking gave an example
of where is the value coming
from a lot of the AI projects?
And as you think about it,
it's usually the more obscure,
far reaching elements, not the basics
that are delivering the most value.
So you need to have a wide spectrum
of areas you're investing in this space
as you're going through it in that regard.
- To summarize this section,
if you're gonna remember
anything, let it be these things.
So traditional cloud
cost planning for that,
we'll leave you three to five X short.
So plan for that from the beginning.
You can't control when or
if AI features get adopted,
so instead focus on cost per
user, cost per transaction
or focus on optimizing model
selection or token efficiency.
And then don't let the fact
that you can't measure ROI value stop you
from investing in AI.
Think outside the box.
Think of those proxy metrics,
time reduced, errors reduced,
things that nature.
So now let's talk about
building the strategy,
putting it into action.
I'm gonna start with AI for finops.
So this follows the crawl,
walk, run for anyone who's familiar
with the finops foundation.
So we've got phase one,
it's the base camp,
it's your foundation.
This is when you're building the basics.
You're tagging, your data quality.
What does success look like here?
This is when your team
can ask simple questions
in natural language and
get an accurate answer.
Then you have the climb, the enablement.
This is when you're scaling intelligence.
This is when you have more
conversational interfaces
for more teams
and you've got those
auto-generated recommendations
that are actually useful.
Success here is your finops teams
are no longer pulling
reports, but they're doing
that strategic proactive optimization.
And in the summit, automation.
This is a mature state.
This is self-healing optimization.
This is when you've got
predictive controls in place
that are preventing waste proactively.
Success here
is you've got those
auto-generated recommendations
with autonomous execution.
And those cost surprises
are starting to become
a thing of the past.
I'm not gonna spend a
ton of time on this slide
because we don't have a ton of time.
We've got a pretty good amount of time.
Before I hand it over to
Chris, I just wanna mention,
you don't have to be at
the summit to get value.
We spoke with a lot of companies
who are recognizing ROI
at base camp, and if base
camp is where you are,
you're where you need to be,
you're where most of the market is.
- Yep, and as we think a very
similar construct on the path
for finops for AI, as you
think about the base camp,
a lot of this is around visibility.
I know a lot of organizations
are yearning for insight
to how are we leveraging AI,
how much are we investing in it?
Where are the ways we're investing in it?
It sounds very similar to what
we just talked about before.
You need to have the
right level of perspective
and inside of who's consuming
it inside of the organization.
On the optimization,
it's obviously all about model selection
and a lot of choice.
I know there's a lot of evolution
moving from large language
to more targeted small language
models that are targeted.
There's kind of three legs
of the stool around speed,
accuracy, and cost as you
think about those three legs.
And not every use case is the same.
And there's a lot of levers you can pull
to drive optimization
as you go through this.
And then lastly on the summit is,
it's around that embedded
governance, predictive elements
and being able to plan capacity,
especially on the GPU side in
the right and effective way.
We did include a bunch
of the details as well.
And I'll pull those up as you have them,
as you see them there.
And it's a evolution you would expect
as you go through this,
which is what are the
right metrics to look at
to assess this?
How do I then evolve the
right accountability model
and link this to business outcomes?
And then ultimately, how do
you have preventative planning
and levers as you go through it?
There's a lot of levers that
exist to drive automation,
I mean cost efficiency of using AI
and there's a lot of
options that exist there.
So taking advantage of those options
is an important element
as we go through it.
- Okay, we're in the final
stretch, so we're gonna do tips,
then we're gonna do
educational recommendations
and then advice from
leaders and that'll wrap it.
So if you're gonna remember
anything from today,
it's these five things.
You're not alone, 90% of organizations
are still in the early phases.
I know I'm a broken record with this,
but data quality beats AI
sophistication, always.
No amount of AI magic is gonna compensate
for that poor data.
Human judgment still matters.
Use AI to accelerate, humans to validate.
Solve for real problems.
Don't deploy AI because it's cool
or because everybody else is doing it,
I know you mentioned it at the beginning.
Deploy it because it solves a painful,
expensive or repetitive problem.
And then as I mentioned at the beginning,
never stop learning.
And on that topic, from
the leaders we spoke to,
we started to just gather
people that they follow,
podcasts that they listen to.
We even got a query, this is
from an individual on my team,
Adam Richter, that he
does almost every day
just to kind of stay up with
everything going on in AI.
So take a look at these follow.
- I'll call out one of my favorites.
There's a lot of greats one up there.
But the AI Daily Brief, if
anybody doesn't listen to that,
they do a really good job as a podcast
to highlight the five minutes of insight
that you need to learn of
what's happening in AI that day.
Then they go into a deeper dive element.
So I know time is sensitive for everyone.
So if you could devote five minutes,
the AI Daily Brief under
listen is a must listen to
from my vantage point if
you wanna stay informed
of what's evolving and
happening out there.
- Awesome.
- Great.
So we'll wrap with some
advice that we heard,
and these are direct quotes from leaders
that we met with as a part of it
and a part of the conversation.
So the first one is around the data side.
And the quote was, we thought
we could kind of skip this
and just go right to it.
I know I get a lot of structured,
unstructured data questions.
How do I leverage this?
I know the gold inside of
companies is their own data.
It's not just the large language model.
It's pairing that with the insights
and the information you
have in your organization,
and spending time and integrating
those two together is key.
The second is around humans in the loop.
Make sure there's good fact
checking, good frameworks.
I loved the loop you had,
specifically around the process
that you can integrate on top of it.
Third is it's all about painful problems
and repetitive problems.
Don't just assume a
dashboard solves issues.
You need to make sure it's integrated
and being shared in a way
that's actually solving
customer's problems.
The whole buy versus build.
I know there's kind of a hybrid answer
which is you're likely gonna buy an LLM.
Some companies here,
many large enterprises
may build a lot of their own.
Most are buying, but it's integrating that
with your own data is the key,
and that's where you can
have an in-house solution
to integrate that together.
And this is all about experimentation
and taking time to do that.
And then lastly is while
the words are different,
don't overthink it, finops basics exists.
I don't know what your viewpoint is,
but I would say finops has matured a lot
over the last several
years, but I still meet
with a ton of customers
that haven't gotten started
yet in this regard as well.
So I think learning the basics here,
you're at a really good time,
especially if you're
maybe in the early stages,
to be able to leapfrog
and mature your practices
and finops by using some of
the AI capabilities that exist.
And just to bring home the summit analogy
or reading through this, the
base camp's where you prepare,
the climb is where you grow
and the summit's where you see the view,
but you can't do it standing still.
So it's an element of really important
to get started in this regard.
Obviously AWS can help you.
There's great partners out
there that can help you.
So if you're interested, I
definitely would reach out
to your account team to engage on this,
to learn more and to hear more about it.
- And then I just wanna wrap.
I was talking about my
son at the beginning.
And I share this
because this is from like
two, three weeks ago now.
And I share it because he's
thriving in my humble opinion.
And I don't think we could
have gotten him to this state
without the subject matter experts,
the community that have really helped us.
And we want to be that for you.
And as Chris mentioned, reach
out to the account teams,
engage us, let us help you.
And then of course this is
our QR codes for our LinkedIn
if you wanna connect.
We will also stay outside
for any questions after.
And then please, please do the survey.
Feedback is a gift and we
wanna continuously get better.
So with that being said, happy re:Invent.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)